bienvenue dans l'univers des cosplay des
mangas et des créatures en tout genre
j'ai voulu moi aussi un immergé à dans
cette culture et dans cette réalité est
différente
suivez moi alors la première étape pour
se transformer et bien c'est la pose de
la perruque et vous allez voir qu'il ya
une technique assez particulière c'est
quoi cette équipe audrey alors tout
d'abord vous devez mettre un pied à
cheveux ça permet de plaquer tous les
cheveux contre m deuxième étape en fait
ça va être juste il a day
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le tour est joué je suis prête alors
évidemment pas de cosplay sans costume
j'ai fait le bon choix parmi tous les
stands qui a ici à au chap une bourre
festival qu'est ce que vous en pensez
alors c'est ici que la magie opère avec
le maquillage je suis en compagnie
d'ophélie qui va me faire me transformer
le visage qu'est ce que vous allez me
préparer au pays donc je vais faire un
maquillage très simple au niveau du
regard et rajouter de la paillette pour
rio c'est pour aller avec le costume et
la perruque c'est parti
[Musique]
voilà la séance maquillage est terminée
j'ai un peu l'impression de me retrouver
dans la peau de cléopâtre en mode
cosplay mais c'est plutôt agréable
voilà l'expérience cosplay et mangas
c'est terminé pour moi pour aujourd'hui
mais vous avez jusqu'à dimanche pour
venir ici au japan tour festival
quant à moi et bien je vous quitte en
bonne compagnie a très bien
[Musique]